ce sont deux hommes deux femmes qui
meurent des enfants qui meurent pas
besse ii le tchad qui a mobilisé des
blindés contre boko haram invite les
pays africains à se joindre à ses
efforts militaires contre la secte
islamiste
son président souhaite une coalition à
l'image de celles qui luttent contre le
groupe armé état islamique
faut dire que le conflit se propage aux
pays voisins avec moi sophie langlois
ce fut d'abord pour bien situer les gens
il faut dire que le fief de boko haram
et au nigeria ils contrôlent
littéralement une partie du territoire
ils contrôlent une bonne partie du nord
du nigeria là où la secte boko haram
sévit depuis une dizaine d'années donc
les trois états du nord-est sont en état
d'urgence depuis 18 mois
ça veut dire que cette région là est
bouclée par l'armée qui devrait protéger
patrouiller la population mais c'est pas
ce qui se passe
pourquoi ne cessent d'intensifier ces
attentats ces attaques
une attaque sanglante à bagua près du
lac tchad
il ya dix jours a fait plus de 2000
morts dont clairement l'armée du nigeria
riespach contenir la beaucoup à boko
haram qui a attaqué derrière des civils
pour la première fois dans un village du
cameroun donc le cameroun le pays juste
à côté on a donc des attaques hier qui
ont fait trois morts et on a kidnappé 80
personnes mais tout de suite l'armée
camerounaise a lancé une traque qui a
réussi à faire libérer aujourd'hui 24 de
ses otages
c'était aussi la première fois la
semaine dernière que boko haram attaqué
une base militaire où cameron donc
s'inquiètent de plus en plus les pays
voisins c'est pourquoi le président du
tchad a décidé de retirer ses troupes
une bonne partie de ses troupes qui sont
au mali en ce moment pour combattre aqmi
al qaïda au maghreb islamique pour les
déployer plus tôt au cameroun
possiblement juste qu'au nigeria
parce que ces pays voisins là on besoin
particulièrement le tchèque qui n'a pas
d'accès à la mer a besoin du cameroun
pour son commerce mondial mais il ya
aussi le niger une frontière très longue
avec le nigérien beaucoup moins bien
défendu que celle du cameroun et du chan
on soupçonne boko haram du cash et des
otages là-bas le niger aussi qui est aux
prises avec 115 mille réfugiés du
nigeria le tchad et le cameroun comme en
sus et être envahi par ces réfugiés et
ils n'ont pas les moyens de faire face à
ce flot de réfugiés
mais sophie le niger n'est quand-même
grandes puissances africaines comment se
fait-il qu'il n'arrive pas à éradiquer
ce groupe armé maucourant les gens du
nord ils sont des dizaines de millions
accusent le gouvernement de goodluck
jonathan qui est du sud qui est chrétien
alors que le nord est à majorité
musulmane de les abandonner de ne pas
mettre les moyens nécessaires pour
combattre
boko haram c'est effectivement une armée
puissante qui a beaucoup plus de moyens
que celle du cameroun par exemple
or on voit que cameron qui y met les
moyens réussi à des résultats et donc
vous voyez on est en campagne électorale
et pour pour le gouvernement ça semble
être une quantité négligeable les
électeurs du nord la commission
électorale a avoué qu'elle ne serait pas
capable d'avoir des bureaux de scrutin
les élections auront lieu quand même
c'est pourquoi la communauté
internationale maintenant doit faire
pression sur le gouvernement pour qu'il
agisse très intéressant merci beaucoup
ceux ci des années nous en parler vous
en prie